well welcome everybody wow
okay welcome everybody thanks so much
for joining me today my name is Brandon
mik and in this session we'll be talking
about correcting common async await
mistakes
in.net now I'm going to be moving fast
because async await came out a long time
ago and every new release ofn net has
come out with more async aake goodies so
there's more had to add into this
presentation so it's about an hour and a
half worth of material we're going to
cram into an hour but don't worry
because if you go to this website that I
made for you today Cod traveler. async
best practices you can find everything
recovering today you can find a
recording of this talk from a previous
NDC session you can find the slides
we're going to be looking at open source
samples you can find those on GitHub
they're all linked there as long along
with a bunch of resources if you want to
dive further down this Rabbit Hole um
this is a a special topic for me because
I'm I'm actually a mobile app developer
I make apps for IOS and Android using
zamarin and net Maui and everything
we're talking about today are mistakes
that I've made and it was until I kind
of went down the rabbit hole did I
really understand what was going on so
let's jump into it because we got a lot
to cover now we're going to break down
this method and see what's really going
on uh yes this is old code still using
web client no you should not be using
web client this is not part of the best
practices this is old code like I said
I've been given this talk for a few
years now slides are a little
complicated as you'll see in a second
and I haven't updated them yet but what
we're looking at here is an async task
method called read data from URL we pass
in a string URL then we new up a web
client web client calls download data
task async and we await it which is good
we want to we want to await that task
because if download data task async
takes a couple seconds well we want that
to be happening on a background thread
we don't want our UI to be tied or UI
thread to be tied up and processing
stuff in the background so what's
actually going on here well let's say
thread one kicks off this method so
thread one jumps into read data from URL
it news up web client and in the signs
bite array B bite array result um but
then thread one hits that awake keyword
and it returns it goes back to interact
with the user and this is really
important because again thread one's our
calling thread thread one's our UI
thread thread one's our main thread and
thread one is the only thread that can
interact with the user so if we have our
app on the screen and the user starts
scrolling thread one's the only one that
can redraw the UI or if the user Taps a
button thread one's the only thread that
can respond to that button tap so if
thread one was is running download data
task async well let's say it takes 5
Seconds thread one's then Frozen for 5
seconds it can't respond any button Taps
it can't respond to any swipes and our
app's basically Frozen and what happens
next our users you know they force quit
the app they give us a onear review on
the App Store and life's not good but
luckily we have async await so as soon
as we call the await keyword a
background thread will run that task so
a background thread runs download data
task async uh in this case we call it
thread 2 but it could be any thread from
the thread pool uh there's a we don't
have time to dive into it today but net
has a thread pool that it manages for us
so every other thread other than thread
one is a background thread and depending
on the size of your server your phone
whatever is running the code determines
the size of the thread pool so if you
have more CPU power more RAM you'll have
a bigger thread pool than say like a
little Raspberry Pi but when thread 2 is
done when download t t when when
download data task async is finished
thread 2 shouts back to thread one and
goes hey I'm all done you're back up and
thread one jumps back in and thread one
continues running our code so thread one
uh creates that string data by uh
passing in the bite array and then kicks
off that load data method so to really
understand how all this works because
the threads really talk to each other no
they're not people they're just computer
programs we've got to look at the
compiler gener ated code
so what you might not know is anytime
you create an async task method the
compiler creates all of this code for
you now the first thing you'll notice is
the compiler generated a class I didn't
write a class I made a method but when
this code compiles the compiler turns
our async task method into a class that
inherits from I async State machine now
if you look closely these variable names
look very very similar like this class
is called angle bracket read data from
URL angle bracket dore1 you know it's
got a little bit of a funny name but
that's basically the same uh same as my
method name and the compiler does this
on purpose
because we can't we can't use angle
brackets for our our class names that's
an invalid class name if we were to
write that code but the compiler can do
it and it does it on purpose so that it
avoids comp avoids any conflicts so this
way it can generate a class it knows
there's no other class in our code
called angle bracket read data from URL
angle bracket because again that'd be
illegal for us to write but compiler
knows the rules so it can break its own
rules so it generates all this code for
us it generates also all these fields so
every private or rather every local
variable that we created in our code
becomes a field so we have private
string data we've got private bite array
result we have private web client WC and
we have public string URL now that's
public because if you remember URL was
the parameter we passed into the
method now the biggest thing in here and
this is where we're going to focus a lot
on today is this move next method and
this is what used to baffle me because I
I started publishing apps to the App
Store uh about eight years ago and I I
thought understood async A8 I didn't uh
but uh I would get these weird bug
reports these weird stack traces would
come back in like I would see move next
all over these stack traces and I'm like
what is this method you know I I never
wrote a method in my code called move
next and well it turns out it's because
it was autogenerated from the compiler
so let's actually look at what move next
looks like so this is the code that the
compiler generated for move next and
essentially what this is is is a giant
State machine so you can see it's
essentially a giant switch statement
with multiple cases in it and the way
this works every time we use the await
keyword the compiler will generate
another case so in this example we use
the awake keyword once so we have two
cases if we were to use the awake
keyword twice we would have three cases
if we use the awake keyword four times
we would have five cases so for every
awake keyword it generates another case
in our switch statement and if we look
at case Zero we can see this is
basically our code leading up to that
first await so we we initialize that web
client we kick off download data task
async s it to a variable called a waiter
zero and then we return so this is this
is the magic this is how thread one
knows to leave the method and it can
just return to continue interacting with
the user continue handling those button
Taps scrolling drawing on the screen the
because it knows download data task
async is going to be run in the
background on a different
thread now before it returns though it
sets that value of PC to one and this is
important because remember when thread 2
is done it shouts back to thread one and
goes hey you're back up and thread one's
got to jump back into our code and the
way thread one knows where to pick up
where it left off is from that variable
so it set the new state that PC variable
to one so now it knows it just jumps
back into case one where it gets the
result from download data task async
encodes that bite array into a string
and runs that method called load
data
now here is the gotcha this is the
biggest problem that causes the most
headaches that in uh C code that I see
today and it's because everything in
move next is wrapped in a tri catch
block now now I didn't write a tri catch
block but what the compiler did it took
all my code and put it inside of this
Tri catch block so this means that if
any of my code throws an exception it's
going to be caught by this exception
Handler and now that's usually okay
because as long as we use the await
keyword when we call the task as long as
we say
await task that exception gets
rethrown but if you don't the task that
exception disappears and it's gone
forever and this was the biggest problem
of mine uh when I first started out when
I started making mobile apps using zamin
publishing to the App Store and the
weird bugs I was seeing was because I
thought I was being smart I knew about
background threads and I knew about a
single weight or at least I thought I
did uh so I would say things like task.
run and put a bunch of Co in there cuz I
knew I wanted the UI thread to be free I
wanted this code to run on a background
task but I didn't care when this code
finished it was just a background task
so I didn't a wait task.run so I would
just say task. run boom go ahead and
what I didn't know was that code was
throwing an exception but because I
wasn't awaiting the task that exception
was caught in this exception Handler and
it was never bubbled up to me the
developer so I never caught it in any of
my testing and it would happen you know
in weird scenarios that didn't expect
just like exceptions usually do uh now
you might thinking well wait a minute we
got rid of exceptions that's a good
thing right no exceptions are good we
want exceptions to be thrown because
exceptions happen when there's an
exceptional case when there's something
that we didn't write code for that the
system doesn't know how to handle occurs
that's when exceptions get thrown so we
want exceptions to be bubbled up to us
so that we can handle them gracefully
whereas with my code when I said task.
run put a bunch of code in it didn't a
wait it those exceptions were getting
caught never resurfaced to me so that I
could handle them and then what happened
to my apps was my apps now in this weird
state that I never planned for you know
it's like if somebody's on a bus using
my app and they try to press the submit
button and it fails because maybe the
bus goes through a tunnel well what
happens well I don't know because I'm
assuming that it finished successfully I
never realized that my exceptions were
being swallowed
up okay so let's do a quick
review the async keyword adds about 100
bytes nowadays this is more of a fun
fact than anything else cuz does anybody
really care about 100 bytes I don't you
know we're talking 100 bytes not 100
kilobytes not 100 megabytes not 100
gigabytes this just 100 bytes so this is
more of a fun fact that yes the compiler
has to write some extra code for us so
that extra code makes our app size a
little larger but in reality I don't
really care about this but if if you are
working on a an embedded system or
Raspberry Pi maybe this matters but just
know that every async class or every
async keyword becomes a class and that
adds about a 100 bytes to our app
size and we want to await every task
because like we said non awaited tasks
hide exceptions and that's a bad thing
we want exceptions to be rethrown
bubbled back up to us as the developer
so that we can handle them gracefully
and we can tell our app what to do if
our app this is internet connection for
example okay so let's actually jump into
some code here I've I've got a sample
app and again this is all open source
the links available on on the website
and I'll give you a chance to uh grab
that link before we finish again today
but this sample app is it's just an app
that I made to pull down the top stories
from Hacker News if you've never heard
of Hacker News it's just a it's a cool
website where people can share um cool
text stories so if you're into that
stuff you can check it out I like to
flip through it every now and again um
and so I made this app that goes out
pulls the top stories from The Hacker
News API and displays them here in the
mobile app so that way I don't have to
click through them and I can just tap on
any of these and I can read the article
right here so let's jump into this code
now again don't worry about memorizing
anything because you'll see we're
working in this class called news view
model bad asyn practices but the good
good news is I've already completed this
for you so there's another view model
called good I in away practices where
everything we're talking about today is
already done
so let's jump into it and the first one
we have here we have to refactor this
method called refresh um now what we're
looking at is this is the Constructor of
my class and I'm calling this refresh
method which is what triggers when the
user does uh pull to refresh on my app
so this is what's going to go go out to
The Hacker News API it's going to get
the top stories and I put this in my
Constructor because it's kind of a bad
experience if a user launches my app and
then they have to manually pull to
refresh like if you're just greeted with
a blank screen you're not going to know
what to do you're going to think the
app's broken so I want that data to be
there so I want to call refresh as soon
as this app launches but here in the
Constructor you know we can't use async
A8 and this is actually a good thing we
because Constructors aren't made for
async A8 Constructors are literally just
to initialize a class as it gets
assigned into memory we're just supposed
to set some variables set some
properties uh we're not supposed to do
any long running tasks in the
Constructor we're literally just
creating an object so that c can put
that object in memory for us so we'll
never be able to use asyn weight in the
Constructor so okay uh what do we do
because I just said we need to await
every task and now we can't well
there's one cool thing we can do I can
create a method here called refresh
where all a
wait that method and then here I'll just
call my new method
refresh my computer just
froze one second guys I have no idea
what's going
on let's see
yep now we're
back sorry hopefully that didn't mess up
anything back there all right so so now
in our Constructor we're calling this
method refresh which is void so I don't
get those squiggles anymore and inside
of this refresh method I'm calling our
async task method refresh and I'm able
to await it
now this is good code it might not feel
like good code because it's async void
right and what are we told as C
developers never use async void async
void's only meant for uh vent handlers
we should never write an async void
method uh well it turns out this is
actually a valid use case for async void
but my problem with that advice when
people say don't ever use it ever use
async void is nobody ever tells you why
you shouldn't use asyn FOID so let's
let's look at why real quick so one one
thing that uh bad thing about async void
is if we scroll down a little bit we'll
see this method here you know it gets
the top stories it clears the collection
and then it inserts all the new stories
into that collection so what if I did
something like this where I start adding
stories to the collection up here
and this is not good because what's
what's going to happen is again let's
say thread one kicks off this method
refresh so thread one comes into here
thread one hits this awake key word and
as we just learned it's going to return
so thread one's going to exit the method
and it's going to continue on so now
thread one's running this line of code
meanwhile a background thread let's say
thread two is running our async task
refresh method and now both of these
both of these threads are interacting
with the top Story collection so what's
going to happen is we just created a
race condition where sometimes thread
one's going to win and it's going to be
able to add this top story before it
gets cleared down here by thread 2 but
sometimes thread 2 is going to win maybe
you have a really fast internet
connection and all those top stories are
cashed and it just comes back right away
so so this is one of the dangers with
async void because if if I didn't see
this method right here you know it's
this one's apparent it's in my face I
call it here it's written two lines of
code or few lines of code down below um
but what if it wasn't right like what if
this method was written by another
developer on my team it lives in a
different class so I don't see right
away that this is async void so I'm just
writing my code you know as a good C
developer and I'm just using
intellisense to feel my way around this
code base and I see that refresh returns
void and as a c developer it's a totally
valid assumption that we can assume
because this method returns void that
this method will finish running before
this next line of code runs but in
reality refresh is still running out a
background task so we've basically just
inserted the future bomb to everybody
else on our team by running an async
void method so that's one of the big
dangers is they might not know it's
async void they might not understand
that we've just created a race condition
so so why else is why else is this bad
well let's say this method throws an
exception
so so now we know every time this method
runs it's going to throw an exception
and and you might think okay no big deal
right I'll just do a little try catch
block here I'll catch every single
exception that pops
up and I'll put the refresh method
inside of that problem solved right well
not really because again remember when
thread one calls this Constructor then
thread one goes into refresh and thread
one keeps running this code until it
hits the awake keyword well thread one
returns so thread one continues on and
thread one's now down here and it's
exited the tri catch block meanwhile
that background thread thread two is
still running this code so this
exception here is about to be thrown and
we've already exited the tri catch block
so another reason why async void is bad
or why it's dangerous is it's almost
impossible to catch an exception so okay
now now what can we do right because
this is this is bad code we don't want
to do this we don't want to uh you know
set these landmines for future
developers on our team
well what we can do let's bring this
code up and let's blow away async void
because I don't like it either even
though it is valid um so what I've done
for you is I've actually written a
library called safe fire and forget uh
this so this is an extension method that
you can add on to the end of any task
and what it does is basically what we
just talked about so if I go to the code
here because this is actually the code
for that Library this is just the sample
app that lives in it and we scroll all
the way down here to see how it handles
safe fire and forget you can see what
I'm doing for you is I'm wrapping your
task in a TR catch block I'm still
calling a wait but this is async void so
it's fired forget meaning as soon as
let's say Say thread one sees that away
keyword it's going to exit it's going to
continue on your task is still going to
run in the background thread so no
worries there um but if your task does
throw an exception I also give you the
opportunity to handle it so what we can
do is we can put a little function in
here and say maybe say trace. right line
and pass in our exception there's
probably a better way to do
it but I can tell it
safe fire and forget means I'm going to
run this in the background and I'm just
going to move on so I know that this
code will
execute right away we're not going to
await this and I know it's safe because
we're still awaiting that task so we're
still able to get that exception if the
exception is thrown so uh so highly
recommend this like I said all this
codes open source so this is this is
that website if you haven't pulled it up
on your phone yet already uh and you can
head to the n get package here called
asyn weight best practices uh I've been
uh publishing this for a while we've got
over a million download so I think other
people like it too or because this is
all open source you're totally welcome
just to copy and paste the code if you
don't want to add another dependency to
your library but the thing I really
really like about sayy and forget is it
it's forcing us to be very explicit so
if another developer comes along they're
going to see safe fire and forget they
might not recognize that right away but
but once they understand this is us
saying we're fire and forgetting we're
we're going to tell this task to go off
and run and the next line of code's
going to run right away it's very much
inyour face it's very obvious that what
our attentions
are okay so first refactor
done now scrolling down here we're
inside this refresh method again this is
what triggers anytime the user does a
pull to refresh on the app and the first
refactor I have here is for this very
iable so what I'm doing here is I'm
creating a task as a variable where
basically I'm kicking off task. delay
and I'm saying wait two seconds and this
variable name is called minimum refresh
time task uh because I want every time
you do a pull to refresh on my app I
want you to see that spinning indicator
for at least two seconds no matter what
even if you have the fastest internet
connection in the world I want to make
sure you see that animation and so later
on this method you'll see we wait for
this task to finish before we end the
animation and this might feel a little
weird or seem a little strange but it's
actually really common um I know in the
in the mobile World probably in the web
world too because we want our users to
have a consistent experience you know if
they pull a refresh and they get all the
data and then let's say all that data
gets cached so the next pull to refresh
takes half a second half a second might
not even be enough time for the
animation to happen so they might assume
that the app didn't trigger the pull to
refresh and so they'll just keep pulling
to refresh and next thing you know we're
blowing up The Hacker News API because
they don't realize that they actually
have the latest data so so I want the
app to take at least two seconds every
time to show the little animation and
the reason I want to refactor this is
because we have a cancellation token
here now as good C developers anytime we
kick off a task we should always pass in
a cancellation token but sometimes we
have use libraries that we don't own so
I can't always go and change a method to
add a new parameter because maybe I'm
using somebody else's nit package right
so there's a cool thing we can
do and it's called weight
async and inside of weight async we can
pass in that cancellation token and what
this extension method basically does is
it bolts that cancellation token onto
the original task so now if my original
cancellation token is cancelled so we'll
test. DeLay So it's a way to essentially
bolt on a cancellation token if for
whatever
reason the the async task method you're
calling doesn't allow it but you know
again we're good C developers so we're
always going to have a cancellation
token parameter and as as luck has it so
is the net team they also allow us to
pass in cancellation tokens so we're
just going to pass it in here instead of
using weight async since it's already
baked in for us
okay the next refactor we're calling get
top stories so what we're doing we're
we're getting the top stories from
Hacker News then we're going to clear
out the previous collection and then
we're going to add them into that
collection in a sorted order um and this
looks pretty good right like we're using
we're using the away keyword async task
method um so why do we want to refactor
this well if we think about what's going
on let's say let's say thread one kicks
off refresh right so so thread one
creates runs this code thread one runs
this code thread one comes all the way
up to here until it hits the awake
keyword and then thread one returns and
so get top stories is going to run on a
background thread great that's exactly
what we want but remember when get top
stories is done it's going to pull
thread one back in So thread one now has
to jump in to clear my clear my top
Story collection and run through this
for each Loop and again thread one
that's our UI thread the only thing
that's can interact with the user so if
that's doing something else that means
it can't handle that button tap it can't
refresh the UI and so you know if this
four each Loop takes 5 Seconds well
thread one is now locked up for 5
seconds our I is Frozen for 5 seconds so
what we can do here is we can add in
configur we
false now this looks a little weird but
it's an it's an extension method on
every task that
tells net to say I don't care what
thread I return on so so again with
configurate false thread one will run
all this code it'll hit the awake
keyword thread one go returns it goes
back it's now interacting with our user
our apps working great everybody's Happy
And now when thread two is done running
get top stories it doesn't go call back
to thread one it just goes to the thread
pool and says hey any available tasks
anybody and it just grabs whatever task
is or whatever thread is available to
continue and running on our code so
highly recommend configure weight false
uh for a couple reasons one we've now
ensured we're not going back to thread
one so you know what if what if this was
a game right like what if what if this
was a a game that had to run at 60
frames a second 120 frames a second so
thread one's going to be really busy
drawing the UI and if we didn't have
configur weight false and by the way
there is configure weight true but
that's just the default so configure
weight true is the same as not doing
anything um but if we did call back to
thread one and thread one's really busy
well our code just sitting here it's
just paused until thread one is
available to jump back in but with
configur weight false we can say hey I
don't care what thread this continues on
threadpool just give me whatever
whatever thread is free and I'm happy so
uh my rule of thumb again I'm a mobile
developer and we use the mvvm
architecture a lot so my realle thumb is
in my view models in my Surface layer
any parts of my code that never touch
the UI I configure away fals everything
uh if I am in my UI layer so maybe I'm
handling a button tap and I need to
redraw something on the page um then
obviously don't use configurate false
because you want to return to the UI
thread to uh update the UI but
configurate false I add it everywhere
where I'm not interacting with the UI
all right another refactor done so let's
keep going down here and here it is so
now we see this is that task we created
earlier so we have our minimum refresh
time task and let's bump this up a
little bit um and I'm calling dot weight
and this is bad um I I have a rule of
thumb with DOT weight and that's never
never never never use dweight dweight is
really really bad um the reason it's
really bad
is when this code gets called so now we
know we're we're not on thread one
anymore we know we're on a background
thread thanks to configurate false so
let's say thread five is running this
code now it's whatever random thread
that the thread pool gave us um so let's
say thread five hits this code and it
hits weight well what weight does it
doesn't release the calling threat so
weight says uhuh thread five you stay
right here you're not able to return you
stay here I'm still going to run this on
a background task so that uh minimum
refresh time task is still running on a
different thread but meanwhile we've
locked up thread five so now without
weight we're locking up two threads when
we only really should be using one now
that can be really really bad if we
didn't put in configur weight false here
like if if we were still returning to
the calling thread if thread one was
down here well now we've just Frozen our
app so really really bad stuff and you
know even if even if you don't make apps
that have UI like maybe you're sitting
there Going H well I uh I only make apis
for the back end I don't have to worry
about this stuff it matters for you too
because every time we call thread weight
or dot every time you call Dot weight
you're using two tasks when you only
should be using one and eventually your
server is going to hit what's called
threadpool exhaustion because there's a
limited amount of threads in that thread
pool which again the beefer beefier your
server the more threads you'll have
access to um but again with weight
you're going to use two threads every
time you only need to be using one and
eventually you're going to run out of it
and that's called threadpool exhaustion
so so what we should be doing down
here is just awaiting
it easy um but the reason I added this
in here is it's it's rare nowadays but
there might still be times where you
can't call async A8 I see it in Old
interfaces like I've had old interfaces
that return a Bo not a task of type buol
that just return a Bool and I have to
implement this method because it's part
of the interface but that doesn't let me
use async a weight so in those rare
cases what do we do because you know
Brandon just told you to never use
weight well there's a better way we can
call get a
waiter get resol now get waiter get
resol is still bad because it's still
still blocking it does the same behavior
as weight so if thread five is calling
this code down here thread five is still
going to be blocked it's still going to
be locked get waiter get res doesn't
release that thread it's still going to
run uh minimum refresh time task on a
background thread so we're still using
two threads and we should only be using
one but the benefit of geta waiter get
result is if our code throws an
exception get a waer g result throws our
exception um the one good side of weight
is it also rethrows the exception just
like uh the await keyword does but
weight and result they both throw what's
called a system. aggregate exception
which if you've never seen those it's an
aggregate exception is an exception that
holds multiple exceptions so in my
experience get a waiter get results way
better because it'll actually throw my
exception with my code in it whereas
with the aggregate exception that's just
another step for me when I'm debugging
code trying to figure out what's wrong
looking at stack traces because I have
to dig into the system. agregate
exception with do weight but with geta
we or get result it'll throw our code
with our exception so it's a little
better than do weight but again if you
can if you can avoid it avoid it and
instead use the aw
keyword okay so next thing to refactor
we've got a method called get top
stories uh turns a task of type Frozen
set and this is actually pretty cool
Frozen set is something brand new in net
8 this actually has nothing to do with
async A8 but I'm really excited about it
so I want to share it with you here um a
frozen set you can think of it like a
list that can never change uh maybe
you're familiar with uh immutable
collections like there's already a thing
called immutable list and a mutable
array and there's I read only list and
so it's like these things already exist
in net why is the net team adding this
in in net 8 um with this they've created
this new namespace called system.
collections. Frozen so there's also a
frozen dictionary you can use well the
reason this is being added in is because
yes you might have an immutable list or
you might be using a type of IAD only
list but it's not really true because
you know C we've got reference types and
anybody can always kind of come in and
swap out a reference to an object in
your list and all of a sudden your list
is different now so with Frozen set your
list will never change so I'm really
excited for this because the way I like
to write my code is anytime I get
results back from an API or pull
anything out of a database I like to
keep that immutable I don't ever want
that to change in case I need to
reference it later so what I love about
Frozen set is it'll never change there's
no way for another developer on my team
to accidentally swap something out in
the list and huge performance benefit
because now net knows there's never ever
going to be anything right writing to
this set it's actually not a list
because it's not indexed but there's
never ever going to be anything written
we're only going to create it once so it
can do a bunch of uh performance
optimization so your reads are going to
be super fast on Frozen set so like I
said nothing to do with asyn weight just
highly recommend it I'm a big fan of
Frozen uh the new Frozen collections
name space and like I said there's also
a frozen dictionary too which also
highly recommend so
we're looking at this code here right we
we're supposed to refactor this method
but you know I'm seeing we're using
async of weight we're calling configur
weight false and this looks pretty good
I mean you know it it does kind of suck
that we have to call configure weight
false every time um but that's kind of
is what it is you know I worked at
Microsoft for about seven years and
worked closely with a net team and I
would always poke him I was like Hey
guys give me give me a flag give me a
global flag that I can say configurate
false is the default cuz I'm tired of
writing it so much but they haven't done
it yet maybe someday we'll get that uh
it doesn't exist today it doesn't exist
in upcoming version of net 8 so for now
we just got to call configure weight
false every time uh but that's okay and
so this looks pretty good but one thing
we can do better is we could turn this
into an IAS sync innumerable now we
don't have a ton of time today so I'm
going to cheat a little bit and I'm
going to go over to my good async O8
practices class and show you what this
looks like um so if you haven't heard of
IAS sync inumerable IAS sync inumerable
is what allows
us to call a wait for each so maybe
you've used a wait for each in your code
uh if you haven't what it's doing is
it's awaiting this task um but this task
is innumerable meaning you can enumerate
through it you can move to the next one
so what happens is we call a weight and
again we still want to call configure
weight false we always want to pass in
our cancellation token because again
we're good C developers um but basically
it's just a for each Loop that every
time there's a new value provided back
in this async method it'll run this code
so what's really cool about this and
here I'll jump back to the bad one um to
show you for reference you know this bad
one is I don't like it because we have
to first get the top story IDs The
Hacker News API kind of sucks because I
can't just say give me the top stories
instead I have to call the first API and
say give me the IDS of all the top
stories and then once I have the ID
numbers I have to make subsequent calls
for every single story to say hey for
this ID give me the story so I don't
know who came up with that idea who
wrote that API I hate it but that's what
this code is doing right it's doing
everything in serial so one at a time
it's a waiting getting the next story
and this is really slow because what if
I have 50 top stories what if I have a
100 top stories well now I'm going to
have 100 API calls one after each other
that sucks so with isync inumerable if
we jump into here what I'm doing is I'm
creating a list of tasks and what I'm
doing is saying for every story that I
have an ID
for kick off this task so this task the
API hackernews API service. gstory will
start running
so now I have 50 API calls all running
in parallel and then the way I handle
this is I just have a while loop so in
my while loop I have I just say do I
still have any tasks left and I also
give the user the ability to limit it so
maybe they only want 10 stories um they
can do that so as long as we haven't hit
their limit and as long as we still have
tasks left uh we can use what's called
task. when any so task pass. win any we
pass in a list and anytime well
specifically a list of tasks and anytime
a task in that list has
completed it'll give it to us so when I
say await task. when any the first API
call to return and complete it gives me
that task of type story Model so what I
do is because it's done now I can remove
it from my list and then I grab the
story out of it and we call yield return
to return that story with which again
triggers our for each Loop so then this
code runs it's added to the list and our
user is able to see these stories
rolling in in real time and it's way
faster because we're making all those
API calls at the same time instead of
waiting for them one at a time to come
back um if you've never heard of yield
return um this doesn't actually exit the
method it's it's an ie numerable thing
where it can return partial results back
so that's how it's getting those partial
results back to our a wait for each Loop
um one other cool thing with isync
enumerable because again good C
developers always allow us to pass into
cancellation tokens so we've got that
here but iyn enumerable has this cool
thing built in called this enumerator
cancellation where if I just apply this
attribute to let net know that yes this
is the token that I want to cancel this
method then in my code I never have to
write anything like this never have to
check that cancellation token I never
have to see if it's been cancelled I
never have to worry about throwing it
because as soon as this cancellation
token is cancelled because I've given it
this enumerator cancellation attribute
net knows okay break this method we got
to move on we're done so really really
cool highly recommend I think
innumerable you know the um the Json do
the net Json team system. text. Json
there we go the system. tex. Json team
uh they've added in a bunch of features
to support isnc innumerable so a lot of
it's baked into HTTP client for us too
so all of this is really really cool you
can even use it in your apis that you
build in asp.net
core okay so we'll pretend like we
refactored that even though even though
we didn't but we looked at it we talked
about it that still
counts okay the next thing to refactor
um I have this method called get story
and all it's doing is calling my Hacker
News API service and calling that g
story API and if we look at this the git
story method returns a type of task
story Model and my git story method also
returns a task of type story Model so
there's something really cool we can do
here we can actually get rid of the
async keyword and we can get rid of the
awake keyword and we can just return
that task now this probably feels a
little weird because we're not awaiting
it um but this is really cool because we
just got a little performance benefit
because if I go back and put that code
back in and we think about what's going
on here if we say thread one calls this
method well thread one comes in here
immediately hits the await keyword and
returns this code runs we get the top
story and then I mean if we had
configurate false it'd be a little bit
better here but without configur weight
false now it's going to call thread one
back in here and thread one's just
coming in here to return the value so we
just switched threads twice which is not
cheap I mean it's it's relatively fast
you know we're talking Nan but we don't
need to do that because we can just
return the task and then we avoid an
additional unnecessary thread switch so
we can get a little performance boost by
doing this so one of my rules of thumb
is if you have a method where the only
place you use the await keyword is in
the return statement instead of saying
return a wait just return that task
check okay last thing to refactor here
we've got another method called get top
story IDs and you know I I just said it
I just said anytime we have a method
where we only use the awake keyword in
the return statement we should return
the task
so is that should be what we're doing
here right you now we can return the
task and we've got another return
statement up here but that's okay
because we can say task. from result and
we can pass in
there we go so all this looks fine this
is going to compile but this is actually
a trick question this is this is one of
the exceptions to that to that rule that
I just introduced you to because in this
case we're inside of a tri catch block
and so if we if we think about what's
happening in this code uh let's say
again thread one calls this method it
comes into here if statements false so
we get to here and we go to get the top
story IDs but thread one just return so
we just hit this return statement so
we've exited this method we're no longer
inside of get top story IDs anymore
which means we're also no longer inside
of this Tri catch block so caveat to the
rule that I just shared with you is if
you do have a return await inside of a
tri catch block keep it and again that's
that's from a lot of experience where
I've made that mistake one too many
times um another another place where we
want to keep that is if we have a using
block so think about I disposable right
we can say using blah blah blah we've
got our brackets and at the end of that
using block that object's going to be
disposed and I've also added bugs to my
app where I didn't return a wait because
I said I don't need it I want to save
the thread switch and again what
happened was we returned we left the
meth method which means we left the
using block which means that object that
I needed just got disposed and weird
errors happened so if you're inside of a
TR catch block or if you're inside of a
using block keep return a weight uh if
you're not you don't need it now what
can we do here you know I mean I see
right away we don't have configurate
false shame on me so let's put that in
there um but this all looks pretty good
however we have this line of code here
we have we have a spot in our method
where we don't use the awake keyword
so what I've done here is again to
prevent from my users from just
hammering The Hacker News API I say if
you've if you've already gotten the data
within the last hour you know the top
stories don't change that much you know
I don't want somebody sitting there and
just calling the API all day um so to
try and limit that I say if the data is
recent within an hour then just grab the
IDS we've already got you know we can
refresh the links and we can still do
everything but we don't need to make
another API call
and now we're in an async method where
we're not calling the await keyword and
if you think about this this is the hot
path of our method this path here will
be called more than this path so the
first time the user launches our app the
data is not going to be recent so it's
got to go get those top story IDs but
then the second time they refresh the
app we're going to go down this part of
the method and the third time we're g to
go down this part of the method so the
majority of the time this method gets
called we don't use the await keyword
there's something cool we can do instead
of returning a task we can return a
value task now value task is kind of the
same thing as a task it's it's not
exactly the same and again I've got some
documentation on the website for you
where if you want to dig down deep into
this you can see the exactly all the
differences uh but the biggest
difference is value task is a value type
and if remember in C we've got reference
types and we've got value types
reference types live in the Heap value
types live in the stack and the reason
why value task is better in this case
because it can't do everything a task
can do but if we're just doing a method
return totally fine you have nothing to
worry about with value task um but
because value task ises on the stack it
can just pop it right on or push it
right onto the top of the stack which
that's an O of one that's super fast
whereas anytime you have to add
something to the Heap it's got to be
indexed it's got to have a hash so those
are a little bit more expensive and so
in this case where we know we don't
really need all this extra benefits from
the task and especially because the hot
path of our code doesn't use the await
keyword then we can just return value
task and get a little performance boost
here and done all right so we fixed the
code so I know I threw a lot at you so
let's do a quick review um these asyn
best practices never used weight never
use. result uh
nowadays everything should be
asynchronous there's very rare cases
unless you're working on an old code
base or working with an old codebase
like I said the only times I see it
nowadays is if I've got to implement
this interface this interface implements
a method that doesn't return task and
now I'm stuck so I have to use it but
if we can never use do weight never use
do result because it locks the calling
thread so if that's thread one it's
going to keep thread one right here
while it still runs another uh
background task on a different thread so
we're using two threads and our app is
frozen well that's happening so really
really bad things but if you have to
because you're using that old interface
then get a waiter get results going to
be your friend get a waiter get result
returns or throws an exception with your
code in it so if the the method throws
an exception that we're calling. geta
waiter get result on that exception is
going to be your code with uh your
exception instead of weight and result
both throw system. aggregate exceptions
and we didn't show this in the code
today but get a wait or get result also
replaces result it literally has the
same behavior for weight and result so
don't use it hopefully you can avoid it
but in the rare cases where you have to
get a wait or get result will give you a
easier stack Trace debug in the future
uh fire and forget tasks don't don't do
what I used to do and call task. run and
just say yeah this is running out of
background thread I don't care when it
finishes so I'm not going to await it
because like we saw if our code throws
an exception we're never going to be
able to handle it it'll never get
rethrown it'll never be bubbled back up
to me the developer so for fire and
forget highly recommend uh grabbing this
noug get package async await best
practices and using the safe fire and
forget extension method but again it's
open source so if your company's got
weird rules about adding in third party
libraries you can just copy paste the
code I don't mind you've got my
permission avoid return await so if the
only place in our method where we use
the await keyword is in the return
statement we can remove the await we can
remove async and we can just return the
task that helps us avoid an unnecessary
thread switch gives us a little
performance boost but again there be
Dragons Keep in mind if you have a TR
catch block keep return a weight if you
have a using block keep return a weight
because again as soon as you hit that
return statement your codee's exited but
if you have return a wait it's at least
going to wait for that task to finish
before returning so try to avoid it if
you can if you want to get the little
performance boost unless you're going to
try catch block or using
block configur white false like I said I
use this everywhere hopefully maybe
someday the net team will give us us a a
global property where I can say for all
of this code I want configur weight
false to be the default uh until then
you're going to end up writing this a
lot you're going to append it to every
single task um but also keep in mind if
you do need to return to that calling
thread um so for UI things you always
want to return to the UI thread so you
can update the UI you don't want to use
configure we false uh another example
Entity framework EF core can be fickle
with this sometimes needs everything to
be on the same thread so some places
where you don't want to use configur way
Falls yes but my rule of thumb for me is
a mobile app developer making net Maui
apps if I'm in my view model layer if
I'm on my services layer of my app where
I'm never going to touch the UI and I'm
not using crazy things like any the
framework I can figure way Falls
everything to get that performance
benefit so I don't have to return to the
calling thread now there is a caveat to
this uh we didn't have time today to
jump into What's called the
synchronization context
uh again that's linked on the website if
you want to dig into it but basically
the synchronization context is what
helps your helps you get back to the UI
thread um so pretty much every NET
Framework has a synchronization context
uh but asp.net cord doesn't so there's
this weird caveat with configurate false
because asp.net cord doesn't have a
synchronization context to tell it I
don't care what thread I return to so by
default on asp.net core you're always is
or rather you'll never return to the
calling thread you're always going to go
back to whatever threadpool thread is
free uh just something to keep in mind
you can still call configure we false in
your asp.net core code it's not going to
break anything I actually still do it as
a best practice just in case we need to
copy paste that code into somewhere else
but there is a thing called
synchronization context and asp.net core
doesn't have one but zamin wind fors WPF
wind UI Blazer pretty much every other
NET Framework configure Way Fall else
use it value task so if your method's
hot path doesn't call the awake
keyword return value task you'll get a
little performance boost like we said
value task is a value type whereas task
is a reference type so instead of going
through all that overhead of
initializing a task that you're never
going to use we can use value task
instead but there are small differences
like you should never reuse a value task
you shouldn't pass around value task
variables but you know if you're just
creating a method and you're just going
to await the method that's totally cool
and by using value task we can get a
little bit of a performance boost in our
code iyn inumerable so this was that
that cool method that gave us the await
for each Loop highly highly recommend it
it's a little weird to implement like we
saw in my code you I had to create a
list of tasks and put them in a while
loop and it looks a little weird but I
promise you'll get used to it and once
you do it's beautiful because as soon as
those tasks are done we get those
results and for me as a mobile app
developer I can start updating stuff on
the list so the user's not sitting there
waiting for every single story to finish
before I display it to them they'll see
the stories appear in real time as the
API calls finish so highly recommend it
I think Anu bable it is like I said it's
a little strange it's a little weird to
get used to but totally worth it and
remember we always want to pass in
cancellation token to anytime we have a
async task method same is true with
isync enumerable but we want to add this
enumerator cancellation attribute to
that cancellation token so that the isnc
numeral just stops for us so net helps
us out with that weight async so
remember if there's ever a method where
you have to await it you should be
passing a cancellation token but
sometimes sometimes that exists where
the developer didn't give us that option
so if you ever hit one of those
scenarios totally okay because you can
still call weight async at the end and
basically just bolt on that cancellation
token so it's essentially a way to still
pass in a cancellation token to that
task even if that developer before us
didn't allow us to do
it all right there is one thing we
didn't talk about today uh or we didn't
look at in code rather but it's really
important and it's really really cool
it's called I async disposable so we've
talked about eye disposable where you
know it's a using block and when that
using block is finished then you can
dispose properly of objects so for big
things like file streams we always want
to make sure we're good developers and
we dispose of those with uh with net now
we also have I async disposable and what
I want to show you is just how this
works because it's a it's a little weird
it's a little unintuitive at least it
was for me um but the way it looks is we
say a weight using and then we can we
still want to say configurate false
assuming we don't want to return to the
main thread and the way this executes is
that it'll run all the code inside this
block so we say we're saving the data to
the file and then once this code is done
at the closing squiggly curly bracket
that's when we await the disposing of
this uh file stream so so file stream
it's a it's a net API they've already
implemented IAS sync disposable for us
and as long as we say await using then
we get all the benefits of being able to
offload disposing of that file IO object
onto a background thread so we get a
little bit more performance so yes file
stream existed before iyn disposable did
so it's also it also implements I
disposable so you can still just say
using instead of await using but if a
method or if a if a if a class
implements isync disposable you should
probably use a weight using instead of
just
using okay so if you haven't had a
chance now is the time to take out your
phone phones grab a picture of this
slide because this link is where you can
find everything from today I know we
moved really fast like I said there's a
lot of information here um but these are
all lessons learned that I made along
the way when I thought I was doing
things right turns out I wasn't and it
wasn't until you kind of really dig down
deep into the net runtime do you really
figure out what's going on so here on
this website Cod traveler. async AWA
best practices that's that's my web page
you can find everything we covered today
so this is where you can find a
recording I've given this talk at a
previous NDC before they recorded it for
us just like they're doing today I'll
make sure to refresh this once the PTO
recording's out for you um so you've got
the recording that you can share with
your friends and co-workers who maybe
couldn't make it today you've also got
the slides if you want to grab some of
these slides and use them go for them
copy them be my guest and also all that
code so the the a the async A8 best
practices library is all open source
it's on GitHub it's got an MIT license
so you're more than welcome to copy
paste any of that code do whatever you
want with it and if you want to keep
going if you haven't had enough async a
weight you want to keep going deeper
down the rabbit hole you can find links
to things like value task and
synchronization context and all these
really nitty-gritty things that probably
most of your co-workers don't know about
but now you can be an expert in them too
thank
you